mr happenswitch
did piano have a duty to consult the
unions in good time over the
redundancies pursuant to section 188 of
the uh trade union act of 1992.
there is absolutely no doubt that we
were required to consult with the unions
we chose not to do that because we
believe she chose to break the law
because
we chose not to consult and we will come
and we are and will compensate everybody
in full for that i recognize that this
is a really when you get in your car and
drive on the motorway you see the 70
mile an hour sign do you sound that's
not going to apply to me i'm going to do
90 because i think it's important that i
do that is that how you go about your
life no no it isn't did the collective
agreements in place between piano and
rnt and nautilus provide for negotiation
over such matters as redundancies
all right could you rephrase the
question
you had collective agreements correct
with rmt and peer
and nautilus that provides for
negotiation over such matters of
redundancies you've done it before why
didn't you do it what was the moral
justification for you not doing that
okay so this is these are very extreme
circumstances let me can i in order to
answer that question fully can i explain
the difference between the operational
uh model that we previously had and the
one that we are moving to so you
understand how fundamental a change it
is and that helps me explain why we had
to take the route we had to take would
you allow me sorry is this is the chairs
already pointed out there's many
companies that have difficulties they
obey the law and they consult with their
but their members through their trade
unions you haven't done that we've moved
from one operating model to another
you haven't you haven't escaped the law
of this country you've still got to do
it within the legal framework you can't
just decide that you're going to absent
yourself from the legal system united
kingdom so it is it was our assessment
that the change was of such a magnitude
that no union could possibly accept our
proposal oh you're right about that
i've never heard such a farcical answers
to a series of questions okay can i move
on chair um in selecting uk employees
most of whom will be uk nationals or
residents or residents when you select
them for dismissal
p was evidently discriminated
against them on grounds of nationality
what was the legal justification for
doing this
to be clear actually these weren't
exclusively uk nationals
they were largely uk nationals but this
isn't this was a group of international
employees
so what are the new rates of pay to be
offered to the new crews how much are
you paying them so the two models the
two models are very different so to
answer that question is a bit more
complicated if you can allow me the time
the previous operating model required us
to have four crews for every ship on
dover cali
the new operating model
um
requires us to have two ship two crews
and pay people when they work so they're
assessed in slightly different ways the
answer to your question is that the
average jersey seafarer was in was paid
36 000 pounds and will receive 46 and a
half thousand pounds so a year and a
third in compensation
so that's part of the answer to the
question the second part of the question
is what are the hourly rates of pay
uh for the new model so the average
hourly rate of pay is five pounds fifty
on top of that there is a pension
contribution there is food and
accommodation
and then
so can i make a couple of points please
so on the routes that are international
routes that are governed by itf
standards we are paying above itf
minimum wages and on
our domestic route which i think was
referenced earlier lanca and ryan where
we are governed by national minimum wage
of course we are paying national minimum
wage and and so uh so the seafarers
aboard the vessels that are leaving
dover the replacement crew
they're going to be paying on on average
paid at the rate of five pounds and 50
pence per hour yes that's below the
national minimum wage of this country
how do you how do you reconcile that
where we are governed by national
minimum wage we will absolutely pay
national minimum wage this is an
international seafaring model that is
consistent with
uh models throughout the globe and our
competitors do you live on it mr heppelt
fifty now could you could you sustain
your lifestyle at five pounds fifty per
an hour
no you couldn't could you why do you
expect people who've got such
responsible jobs to be able to do that
how do you expect them to be able to
feed their families and pay their bills
at five pounds fifty an hour there's a
couple of very very important points
here one yes it's one it's called gas
one's called electric those are the
important points that they can't pay
their bills one couple of important
points please um these uh the seafarers
who are joining us are international
professional seafarers with all the
international certification these are
these are experienced seafarers